we've known each other really really a
long time Wow I don't know
bestie territory yeah Betsy territory we
know each other's parents yes you do an
impression of your dad and I do an
impression of your mom that's that's
weird they're definitely gonna see this
which is making me alone there was it
they're gonna love it all right yeah you
do I didn't know you did your dad my dad
just sounds exactly like Hank from king
of the hill and he yeah let's go oh hi
oh hi Jay hi Jane and then also he
anytime I do anything wrong my dad like
doesn't think I can do any wrong his I
so I could be like dad I murdered
someone and he'll be like will I mean
the world is overpopulated insane your
mom would you can also do we we hung out
with your mom together yeah several
times yes and I notice in your mom is uh
mmm-hmm
she's kind of like popping popcorn she's
like
Oh Peter Steve you like dead on oh my
god it sees it home like I'm not like
that
I was another round of buzzing my dear
friend Jamie Lee everybody Jamie will be
performing at the print sound Tommy fest
in Portland Oregon May 8th through the
11 Jamie Lee everybody thank you Jim
Jefferies good night